we dug into the ET vaults oh no tonight
96 and found Kathy Griffin's first ET
interview we see it yes it's right there
look there we are a few minutes I want
to make sure that my friends laugh
because that's what I'm most nervous
about otherwise I never get nervous oh I
do stand-up but I have friends here
tonight so I want them to think I'm
funny also I hope that there's something
you can use for entertainment tonight
good luck the kind of stand-up that I do
it's a very story oriented and it's
stuff that is true it's all stuff that
really happens to be or my own
observation so I'm hoping that if people
get to know me or maybe they like the
character on the show or they think I'm
funny then they'll let me really do my
thing because I'm not a joke person I'm
a joke man
you know I don't like make up the joke
about the guy that says love with the
dot on his head what's that about I
don't do I'm not an Arab I walk into a
bar type of humor so the worst bomb I
ever have I did the macho comedy fest
last year and I did it so bad that there
wasn't even like exit applause there was
nothing and just here my little Doc
Martens clip-clopping upstage but that
doesn't happen to be on cabaret oh my
gosh and the curly hair is back yes that
was two noses ago I love the nostalgia
watching that back what do you think of
Kathy in 1996 can I tell you what
surprises me it's surprising how similar
my sort of philosophy is like besides
the fact that I was like oh I have my
real actual curly hair back
very shallow but I was thinking yeah I
still say that like I just want to make
people laugh more than anything I don't
do like knock-knock jokes I don't do the
difference between New York and LA and
so the dogs thinking so it's it's funny
like when people ask that question which
I know you won't like what would you say
to six-year-old Kathy right now you know
I always say you know I tell her to be a
[ __ ] and make some good money which is
for the gag reel
I guess I'm sort of laughing it all
those years ago and I'm not really that
different and I will I will admit that I
am I am pretty much the same off-camera
you know like I've been this annoying
for decades that's what made me a star
but hopefully honest hopefully funny
first that's my motto funny first so I
love that I was doing the uncap array
didn't do you ever know I'd gone to do
Radio City Music Hall 7400 people that's
what you would tell no I would never
would never believed it but I would say
someday you're gonna do Carnegie Hall
and you can sell it off so fast you're
gonna do Radio City the next night which
no comic has ever done another what am I
I'm sorry what am i doing no I'm not
sure if I'm looking for my light what's
happening looking for Jesus I don't know
found him there were people usually find
Jesus in jail I love when people go to
jail first non-attorney he said they're
considering charging you with conspiracy
to assassinate the President of the
United States which holds the lifetime
sentence two and a half years since that
photo photo can you believe you're still
having to talk about it two and a half
years later it's all I'm asked about so
honestly I'm so thrilled and grateful
that I got to make this feature film
Kathy Griffin a hell of a story I gotta
tell you this doc has got me the best
reviews I've ever gotten in my career
it's insane I've been going to film
festivals this weekend I'm doing the
downtown LA Film Festival at DT L AFF so
you know you can come to see the post in
conversation with myself and my pal
comedy genius Aubrey Plaza it's kind of
unusual it's called a docu comedy
because the first third is very gritty
dust country it's like only shot on our
phones and it's like I call it there's
some gritty knowit makeup crying Cathy I
was detained in every single airport
that I went to I was held for six hours
but obviously it's getting to me how are
you able to find the strength to move
forward pick up and live another day and
not just give in to what felt like the
world was turning against you I just
honestly I felt like it was necessary I
was on a comedy mission you know I'm 58
years old I've been doing stand-up for
40 years I have two Emmys and a Grammy
I'm in the Guinness Book of World
Records for having written and produced
more televised stand-up comedy
specials than any comedian living or
dead sold-out Carnegie Hall in 12 hours
all of that went by the wayside all that
meant nothing I don't have nearly as
many Hollywood friends because many of
them who ditch me never came back which
gave me some clarity but I've got to
know a lot of lawyers a lot of
journalists a lot of politico's and
stuff like that I still have like
honestly my core of good friends
naturally in all this
what relationship was the hardest to
mourn to lose well I think you know a
lot of it was tough I mean my boyfriend
who I live with and he's my tour manager
as well you know his family struggles
with him now in a way that shouldn't
have happened I have not heard from one
person named Griffin in months if not
years even your siblings I live one
sibling matters to them and you know
they think some of it was their own
guilt because I think everyone does know
and what I think hopefully gets a comes
across in that this film is that feeling
you have when you're getting what I call
a dog pile
and you think certain people are gonna
kind of be there for you and sometimes
you get surprised and they're not there
at all and then you have to figure out
okay you know is this someone that has
like a legit reason is this someone that
maybe doesn't have the fortitude to be
my friend after all so it's there's a
lot of nuance involved and I'm kind of
always navigating those waters you
brought up Randy I remember November of
last year you guys released a statement
that you were splitting up we did take a
four-month break I know it's very maury
povich but as I you know I don't think
I'm pregnant in 58 so it wasn't one of
those Morrie's like we both have we're
on a break wink wink and now this
paternity test but yeah we took a little
break and we're back and now you know we
just we just came to the decision like
we've really been through so much
together we now been together over eight
years and we even though he's 19 years
younger we both heard each other went
this is the longest relationship for
both of us you know we should fight for
it and make it work and so we've never
been happier and you know it's one of
those things where it was a lot of
pressure the pressure and I imagine the
family stuff you brought up yeah I
should
very guilty about about breeding that on
him really or anybody that I mean even I
know I'm like sort of jokingly
complaining about my relatives but
honestly I don't want any of them to
have to deal with in a negative way I do
want them to know the real story like I
don't want them to be watching like
propaganda and think like I said that
I'm actually like in a training camp at
Isis because you know my favorite joke
is when people confront me about being
in Isis and they think I'm and Isis I go
I worked in the gift shop for a week get
over it
and they just don't know what to do
they're like did she wait admit it or
did she make fun of me and I'm like the
second it turns out there is such a
thing as bad publicity
now you said you want to get back to a
place where you're getting to do at
least a special year it's like some sort
of a consistent TV presence like I'm
still a TV animal it's still the most
watched medium you know I just want to
do whatever makes people laugh and I'm
really not Precious about it whether
it's a commercial or a special or a
series or a tour or a story are kind a
series I would like to do something that
number one reminds people it's it's
Kathy Griffin that you've known for
years making you laugh primarily
obviously primarily as a comedian and it
would be nice to do something where more
Americans could kind of get back to that
place like obviously I look at Fonda and
I look at the body of work she's had
since her scandal and it may gives me
great joy to go oh good you got over
that you see that she's funny and she's
still an activist and yet she's on a
great show
Grace and Frankie and something like
that is always nice and so I'm always
kind of throwing out a whole bunch of
things to see which people which thing
people respond to probably not a
suddenly Susan revival though you know
who knows who knows I would I would
actually rather that someone bought all
six seasons of my life on the d-list
because I love that a lot of these
streaming services are sort of
rediscovering shows that have a
nostalgia factor
[Music]
everybody's talking about your finger
how I personally am really touched when
anyone comes up to me and says like you
know a guy says I would watch the show
with my mom and we would laugh and then
it made it easier for me to tell her I
was gay or people would say you know
your show was funny and the rapport that
you had with your parents was funny and
so it would be a show that I would watch
with my parents or I'd have you know
housewives saying you know my husband
husband doesn't get you but I never
missed your show I'm always trying to
just make as many people laugh as
possible in any way that I can any
format I have another clip for you to
watch this is one of your celebrity fans
wanted to say hi Oh perfect
hi Kathy I love you so much
my earliest memories of stand-up it was
stealing your specials online where
because they lived in the country didn't
have cable so I do owe you a couple
bucks but I love you so much
Trixie Mattel love her I think she's so
great and I just love Trixie because she
is who she is she does what she does she
has fun I think she has the great
attitude and she's out there and I think
that's what her fans love about her oh
yeah but like real you know they really
I've noticed you know whether it's my
life on the d-list or making this doc
you company people can they can smell
out the phony and so I think Trixie is
popular with her fan base and should
have an even bigger fan base darn it
because she's real she obviously has a
great sense of humor she goes there she
goes all in and I like that and I think
people like that people like if you
you're gonna go in go big or go home you
know
[Music]